CBS News is partnered with the
professional networking site LinkedIn
for our series work-in-progress where we
look at issues facing the American
workforce this morning we focus on how
Millennials are reinventing the
traditional concept of employment
Millennials are estimated to make up
more than a third of the workforce a
recent survey found 43 percent plan to
quit their jobs within two years only 28
percent of Millennials plan to stay in
their current role for more than five
years we spoke to a number of
Millennials who left lucrative jobs in
order to travel they are living in
places like Hawaii France and Washington
State I was working at a luxury travel
company I was a magazine editor one of
the top sales guys in the company I was
just constantly sitting behind a
computer all my works done through email
and that was kind of when I got the idea
I can do this from anywhere times are
changing and certain people like myself
it just doesn't cut it travel with my
husband now and it's truly I mean the
best decision that we ever made we don't
know what's coming any given day but you
can see life as an adventurer
the world is really changing it's not
just that traditional you have to be in
an office to make money there are so
many opportunities out there maybe it's
different for some of us maybe we don't
need that American Dream maybe what we
mean is a little bit different chip
cutter is managing editor of LinkedIn
chip good morning welcome morning what's
at the root of this trend well this
really is a symptom of the job market
today people are voluntarily leaving
their jobs at the highest rate since
2000 the hiring market is strong there
are now more open jobs when there are
unemployed workers so people who are
thinking about quitting are saying this
looks like a really good time to do say
have the confidence to do it there the
confidence to do what they feel think
they'll be able to get another job
pretty easily but see me Reba
Millennials not saving right how are
they able to afford quitting their jobs
in traveling for a year this was the big
question I had talking to people who had
done this as well and they said they
really had to plan for this months in
advance and I think it's important to
note that there are a lot of people who
had to have student loans you just
cannot do this but some said that they
saved for instance $2,000 a month to be
able to travel it depends on where
you're going what your plans
are those who plan to travel throughout
Southeast Asia might be able to do it
cheaper than those were going to Europe
for instance but I think then there are
a lot of different pathways to not
everybody is taking uh sabbatical in
Bali some are quitting their jobs just
to take another position somewhere else
or take a higher paying job
there's only Millennials that are doing
this so we see this across the board but
I think it's important to note that
there's a there is a split and some of
the research we've done we found that
Millennials are more open to consider
multiple careers we see kind of older
generations perhaps a little bit more
unlikely to do so some feel like they
feel stuck in their careers aren't
exactly sure where to go next but
quitting could be an option to get out
millennial decides to do this and maybe
just quit the job take some time off for
travel when they go back into kind of a
shouldn't say the real world but you
don't I mean a more traditional work
force could they could an employer be
sort of like I'm not sure this is the
kind of person I want to hire well that
is a lot of the people that I've spoken
with their fear they say how do I make
sure that I tell this in a way that
makes sense to employers right I spoke
with someone she was working in
investment banking she quit her job she
traveled all throughout Southeast Asia
now she's trying to get a job in
sustainability and she said that she's
now using this travel experience as part
of her story I've seen that part of the
world helped her better understand what
this field but if you're an employer you
want employees are gonna stick around so
but now you're dealing with a workforce
that's ready to get up and leave so how
do you how would our companies adapting
to this this is the big fear right now
across corporate America how do we make
sure we keep our workforce given how
hard it is to hire right now so a lot
are instituting policies flexible work
policies Dell does this for instance
others like the ice cream brand halo top
for example they don't even have offices
they say their employees can work from
home that's one way to solve you can
solve it that way we're from co-working
spaces wherever works best for you halo
top is good just for the record halo
good no offices even better yep so nice
to have you here thank you so much thank
you